our universe is a mystery
it's a collection of mysteries the more
we learn the more we realize that
there's a lot more that we do not know
here are five big Mysteries
there is no reason to believe that our
universe
is unique
it is quite possible that just as our
universe was created many universes were
also created
that is the case then we live not in a
single universe but in a vast collection
of universes that physicists refer to as
the Multiverse we can think of those I
Reland universes each with its own
quirks maybe even each with its own laws
of physics
for example there could be one of these
other universes where gravity is a
hundred times stronger than it is in our
universe
if we could somehow prove conclusively
the existence of multiple universes of
the Multiverse that would be a genuine
intellectual Revolution a complete
change in our Cosmic thinking
the dark side of the universe is a
really big mystery the dark matter and
the dark energy make up no less than 96
percent of what the universe contains
the stuff that you and I the Sun the
Earth the Stars the galaxies are made of
that is just the icing on the cake it
makes up only four percent of what our
universe contains the most likely
explanation for the dark matter is that
it's made of some exotic fundamental
particle that came into exist as just a
tiny fraction of a second after our
universe was formed in the Big Bang but
it is a mystery
we have compelling evidence that it's
there we suspect it's a fundamental
particle but frustratingly it has yet to
be discovered
[Music]
I think most people have heard about
black holes
fewer may have heard about white holes
white holes are in a way the opposite of
a black hole
black holes eat everything
my calls kind of vomit everything out
nothing can come out of a black hole
nothing
can go into a white hole whether white
holes exist or not
it's a matter of heated debate
of course if they do exist
they are fascinating and they may even
raise the possibility
that they act as tunnels to other
universes or indeed
to order ebooks in our own universe but
they remain hypothetical objects
the current View ing cosmology is that
everything we see
we see everything started life as
something called a Quantum fluctuation
sounds be steer let me explain what this
is when the universe was born
it expanded very rapidly
in a very short period of time known as
Cosmic inflation as the universe
expanded
these Quantum fluctuations were
stretched
and the stretching
the universe with tiny ripples
these ripples
yet are the origin of galaxies Galaxy
clusters planets the Earth and people
the mystery here is it's a really
possible
that a sub-microscopic entity like a
Quantum fluctuation
could eventually grow into the Milky Way
galaxies if you had told me that a few
years ago I would have thought but you
ran out of your mind
and yet today the standard model of the
formation of cosmic structure is exactly
what I just described
time
fascinates not just physicists
fascinates everyone
and yet it is a relative concept
for example
if you travel
fasting and faster and faster
time slows down more and more and more
if you trouble at the speed of light
time simply stops
if you look at the equations of physics
it's striking that time can go forwards
or backwards the questions of physics
don't distinguish because of this many
people believe that you can travel into
the past
because there's nothing in the equations
of physics that forbids you doing that
it is quite possible that we could in
principle travel back in time so long as
we do not introduce any inconsistency
with the future
so that's five big Cosmic Mysteries
history
as it's always the case in science
leads to another even bigger mystery
and we haven't even got to possibly the
biggest mystery of them all
are we alone in the universe
well that's a whole new story
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video